rung out already on this cookies of
death and in the [__] showroom my
main man tonight you may know him you
may not know him but that's why I got
him on the show so you [__]
getting on Al Roz on the [__] on the
table what's happening baby what's up
Uncle Joey look at him tatted up like
[__] sons of anak
meets I don't even know Hawaii 5 I don't
[__] know what's happening here today
ER everybody all right we all good man
what's going on just tripping on Lee
over there Le yeah they made fun of me
because that parked too far away from
the wall they made fun of me what the
[__] they made fun of me Co we didn't
make fun of you you park 8 ft from the
[__] wall I come in I go why is this
car in the middle of the parking lot he
comes down like a mty m walking around
with sympatico juice in his face I was
so worried that I was going to hit the
wall and I wanted to make sure I was in
the line but 10t away oh [__] how
worried were
you I was focused on the lines and
forgot about backing up and just cuz
your name is Lee doesn't me you got a
drive [__] up bro oh [__] look at him
dropping knowledge on Le off the bat
look at he scratching his head I don't
get that joke it's a Chinese
joke no you don't [__] get it why you
scratching your head all [__] up like
huh what's the problem you only had a
half I I even cut it back on your ass
yeah and you're
still oh yeah our Ro blz what's
happening baby man just right here
chilling man getting ready for The
Fluffy Movie to drop when is that
dropping July July 11 11 fresh 711
7eleven and you have there's a segment
in the beginning and you guys are all in
it yeah we're all in it's kind of like a
little short film maybe 20 minutes and
um I I play a pervert at a club good for
you harassing Gabriel's Mom good for you
good for you that's that's a good one
right there though I don't saw you to
the
top right you think Grudge Match did
wonders wait till you [__] that comes
out [__] up what what what what are you
laughing about you got the blue shirt
with the white the blue flag behind you
you look beautiful thank you you [__]
jck suck I love you finally see you're
stoned yeah you feel good you're loose
last night you were all tired every time
I called you I can't go call me every 15
minutes I'm going make you eat this
cookie from Death the Russians are going
to come and Fe us 400 Mig a day we got
to be ready
look it's either Russians it's either
the Taliban or the Arabs somebody's
going to come over and they're going to
want you to eat cookies and you're going
to be prepared cuz that's how you roll
you're not some regular [__] juice
from from M lukeville you're a Jew with
balls you got spine you got mink yod
personality H what you think you think
he got Personality yeah he has
personality robers wouldn't be [__]
with you if you didn't have no
personality I know Al I know Al deep
deep deep jungles in [__] columia I
into him one time he had two pounds of
readed I had two pounds of coke we had a
little party and he went his way and I
went my way he ended up in San Diego me
I got another story but [__] we'll tell
that one next podcast
what's happening Church of America you
bad [__] Church of What's
Happening Now if you think Lee is [__]
up I'm more [__] up but I'm going to
sell this [__] I'm not sure what
you just said by the way don't worry
about what I just said all right what's
with the questions Cocker somebody turn
the air on I'm dying over here Le why
did you turn the AR off why did you turn
the [__] arir off Le who told you to
turn the arir off you know I got anxiety
and [__] I hate you Lee was cold bro how
the [__] is Lee cold no it wasn't cold
how the [__] is Lee cold not cold you're
never cold
leuck I was cold when you were 90 with
the AC blasting and the windows open on
the way home from San Diego stab you
anyway what's going on our roess talking
to this [__] guy San
Diego look how Stone he is boy what' you
e for dinner a steak and cheese and
wings how many wings eight eight Wings
what kind of dressing blue chees don't
[__] with me somebody smell my breath
listen I wouldn't smell your breath or
your ass [__] yes you would now
you want your dirty bastard what's up of
you robers tell me something just right
here Joey just [__] getting ready for
that movie just going up on stage and
just trying to get better man you're L
man thank you you're out every night
you're not just sitting at home faning
your [__] like 60% of the comics in La
you bump into them right and they tell
you how bad things are you always make
me smile that's why I figured i' put you
on the podcast you make me smile every
time I see you always got a story you
got a question you got to keep it real
bro keep it real yo I tell you all the
stories I tell you what's [__] going
on in Mexico what's going on in the
streets by my hood what's going on with
Comics dude [__] this [__] is
never slipping you understand me you got
to learn from him maybe you should hang
out with him for a couple weeks he's
always on [__] point he's always got
something an envelope something you know
what I'm saying you give him a [__]
kilo of coke and he'll do it in one
[__] bang and it's all over after
that we're back get together it Lee
anyway
he's all right Le he's all right Le
you're goodly no Le's a good man he's a
good guy man now you started comedy out
here bro I started comedy here in 2002
bro in March that's when I met you 02
back in the days man where did you live
back then I lived in East LA no [__] all
you [__] at East LA is yeah man
just ain't no [__] just like the videos
when I was a kid just like just like
Gangland bro that I live where I live
right now it's kind of like borderline
Eagle Rock in La that's what they they
film the gang Lane about the Avenues
just right they right in the hood bro
what's the Avenues that's a gang it's a
big ass gang in LA are they still there
they're still there wow they're the Run
they're the the gang that runs the
[__] Mexican Mafia [__] out in the
streets so they Coke in there everything
dog I have a funny story man in 2000 I
had I was I was in the police academy
still and um we used to get together
with my neighbors and we used to have
water balloon fights and then with um
with the water guns so we used to run
down the street just throwing water
balloons and shooting each other we to
stop traffic and then the cops the cops
came and you guys are [__] around you
guys stoping traffic you guys got to
stop and like the next day we did it
again and a couple of gangsters came
down they're all like they pulled us
aside and they're all like hey um you
guys got to stop this [__] man you guys
are bringing heat to the neighborhood
the cops are slopping you guys and
they're [__] our [__] up so they made
us [__] stop throwing water balloons
dude I all quick now you you were
studying to be a cop I was in the police
academy they got kicked out for stalking
my ex-girlfriend come on yeah she put a
restraining order on me and I got DQ I
got disqualified for that cuz when you
when you get when you get a restraining
order it's kind of like a domestic so
you can't carry a gun or
anything Jesus Christ where is she now
[__] I don't know bro dying somewhere
yeah putting the kiss of death on you
ready now she did you a [__] favor
yeah she did I was I was looking for her
on Facebook to [__] congratulator
tell her thanks but then I said you know
what that [__] stalking again so I st
she changed her name no I don't know
dude dude I stopped and she hopefully
dude some women take it so [__]
personally yeah I mean I creeped her out
dude I was talking her pretty hard
really yeah were you in love I was in
love back then how old were you I was 21
you had the smell of [__] was driving
you [__] ass driving me [__] crazy
bro it's crazy when sometimes it grabs
you like that I [__] um I I was drunk
this is the last last this is when she
said you know I had enough I was drunk
and she lives in Glendale and I took the
bus to her house like at 10: p.m. and um
I saw her car outside and I jumped a
fence at her house and I knocked on her
window her room window and I didn't
think she was going to be there so I
didn't have no [__] Plan B and she
opened up the curtain and I don't know
what the [__] to do man so the first
thing in my head I went like this I
pointed at my ey and I go I'm watching
you and I just walked oh God yeah I will
throw you in jail for that and you call
the cops and I was at the bus stop
dud yeah they'll throw you in [__]
jail for that
nowadays [__] cuz she's gone did have
you have you been had you been with her
I was with her like for like a year and
a half okay and then you guys broke up
yeah we broke up and then I said you
know what [__] this I'm going to stalk
her man [__] that I burn her [__]
house down yeah [__] that was my next
step dude I don't give a [__] [__] that
man it's amazing it really is have you
ever fallen in love like that LE tell me
the truth I don't give a [__] well it's
easier now cuz it's social media so you
would you wouldn't even have to like go
near our house so yes you would no
you're going to go on social that's half
a [__] [__] stalking so yeah that's
like half no you got to go to the house
and park there and watch it through the
bushes no I'm not going yeah watch yeah
you that's how you that's how you
[__] do you can't be stalking just on
Facebook or on Twitter or anything like
that I'm not doing it anymore but I mean
why like sometimes it's not possible St
stocking is a sport bro you got to dress
up for it you got to [__] do
everything though balls out well I never
did that were you ever in love when you
were young yeah with who who was the
girl which one I don't know who'd you
fall in love with that you [__]
couldn't stop jerking off and dreaming
that you were going to go to a dance
with her and that some [__] P this
girl named Linda and what
happened uh I don't know I was too young
to realize if she liked me or not and
then she moved away and then like years
later we were talking she be like oh I
wanted you to ask me out and
like but who did you fall in love with
that actually gave you a taste of that
monkey and you thought it was the
[__] best thing you ever tasted and
then you couldn't [__] take it no
more you you couldn't take Bean without
it you couldn't [__] wait to get over
there like lick that [__] Muffet it
hadn't really happened with a girl I've
had sex with what happened like it
hasn't really happened with a like I've
never broken up with a girl that I've
had sex with been like ah but she cut
you
off no no I can't think of like I I how
[__] boring are you right what you
you just said you haven't broken up with
the chick that you had sex with no no no
I'm saying it I don't have I haven't had
those like stocky feelings about one of
those oh okay so who do you have
stocking Fielding for like the ones
where I didn't have sex with
them yeah yeah they put it out I
understand what you're saying that the
time I went crazy on [__] was the sixth
grade with the broad Nikki I went
[__] nuts bro I got L back I couldn't
even think straight because I was doing
I was dry humping it I was sucking at
titties but that's it and she told me
the day after school she goes the day
when school ends we're going to [__]
like
[__] bro I was counting the
[__] minutes when you in the sixth
grade you count the [__] minutes I
couldn't focus I couldn't do anything I
couldn't go to karate I couldn't [__]
do anything and then finally the day
after school came and she goes no dog it
was a nightmare it crushed me but I went
after it but by this time I did so bad
at school that they put me in summer
school right in North Bergen you have to
go to if you miss three days they throw
you out dog I missed three the I would
go to school I couldn't even think about
all I kep think about was running back
and eating that [__] monkey and
nothing ever happened and she we broke
up it was [__]
horrendously and was do you think she
gave it to someone else bro or did you
just [__] after that she did yeah and
then years later she bumped into me and
I was going to give her stabbing but by
that time it was too [__] late you
know it's amazing how your life uh
changes like that then when I was 25 30
I fell in love with this Broad
that you know was a freak man when
they're dirty like that you've been in a
bad position for a while one comes along
and let me tell you something it [__]
sweeps you off your feet where you know
I would [__] Climb by the side of a
house I would drive by a house and see
if she was home I never knocked on her
glass but see here's the other thing
about me I stalk all my
friends like I've always been one of
those guys let's say Alfred lives on
72nd Street I live on on 79th and you
live on 65th if when I'm coming home
from a gig at 2 in the morning I'll take
the route that I'll drive by all of your
houses and end up in my house I've
always done that even as a kid I always
did that that was my main thing I always
drive around and see what my friends
houses look like so this broad you know
it was weird it was a weird thing but I
loved her and I didn't know if I trust
her or not you know when you have to
drive by a chick's house you shouldn't
be with it because you don't [__]
trust it you know what I'm saying right
yeah you know what's crazy man I I I was
I was engaged for two years and um I I'm
not with her no more and I remember when
we had just broken up she was all like
oh I don't think you really love me cuz
you talk about your jokes about used to
stalk your ex-girlfriend and you haven't
even stalked me once I go [__] that was
a long time I was a little kid you know
I was young I was 21 don't got a [__]
stocking now so oh that's one of the
reasons why I didn't know you you didn't
you didn't love me you didn't stalk me
like you have these jokes about your ex
and you stalked them and we were engaged
you didn't even stalk me she went
[__] there you were crazy when you
were young yeah I was [__] crazy man
I remember [__] um I was I was dude I
love that chick so I remember stalking
her and I remember she had a man and I
used to stalk that [__] too
bro old school old school when everybody
gets Stu the mother the
father you stalk them all and it was
funny cuz when I got the restraining it
was 90 90 yards away from her 90 yards
away from her car 90 yards away from her
house and 90 yards away from her work
dog wow that's a heavy duty
restra 90 miles from her [__] garbage
everything I had done [__] on
total lockdown like Eddie Bravo in
2014 I was on [__] 90 yards man what
made you try comedy what made you when I
got I got kicked off from the academy
and then I I got that restraining order
and I always wanted to become a comedian
I just I didn't know how to do it my my
older brother really got me into it I
remember he used to have um the the
Andre Di clay tape cassette and Eddie
Murphy and I used to always listening to
I used to listen to it in his room bro
he's stick in his room and listen to it
no D I want to do what they're doing
making [__] strangers
laugh and it's funny cuz now I [__]
hate their style of Comedy bro both of
this yeah
I'm not a big Eddie Murphy fan or Dice
Clay fan but back then I used to love
him but back then [__] now I mean now
[__] well you evolve once you see people
like you see them hang out and stuff so
you evolve as a comic you know but it's
amazing who you like At first who drew
you at first you know the guy who drew
me for sure like I saw PRI got my eyes
open Carlin opened up my eyes and David
Brena opened up my eyes growing up
Freddy Prince but the guy who hooked me
was Andrew Dice Clay oh okay and it's
funny because I had a friend of mine
named Manny and he kept bugging me like
he kept bugging me do you got see this
at track the C uh d uh CD what is it the
CD uh no no not the CD VCR the VCR VHS
saying you got to see this V VHS tape I
got for you it was
endless so for a lot of people who don't
know I got locked up right I got out I
they put me in the halfway house in
February
of
89 they let me out of the halfway house
in September of '89 and I went [__]
bananas I couldn't stop snorting so I
gave him two hot UA so December 1st they
put me back in the halfway house so I
was going have to sit in the halfway
house for Christmas and New Year's Eve
was killing me dog Al robers was killing
me I was a dirty junkie then and I said
you know what what I'm going doing they
had a conference room they had a couple
conference rooms rooms and somebody put
that for 25 bucks you can rent a
conference room and have a party with no
alcohol but get a TV and stuff so I got
the TV and I put Andre Dice Clay live
from Philadelphia and it was [__]
amazing that was you know Hickory
Dickory do yeah right right and all that
[__] it really was amazing did he pushed
me over the top then I watched Rodney
Dangerfield special with the five comics
with Seinfeld and Lenny Clark once I saw
Lenny Clark I had to [__] go for it
did you like Paul Rodriguez and those I
never liked Paul Rodriguez who did you
George Lopez none of those TCO a Willie
Barcena I was a [__] Willie Barcena
fan bro that was the first CD I ever
brought was Willie Barcena no [__] yeah
in 2000 was that CD called it was called
they just
jokes yeah and it was very good it was
very good man I used to look up to
Willie dude I still look up to Willie
you know Willie's a lot of things but
one thing he definitely is a good writer
he's a good writer man he's a bril
brilliant writer he puts time into his
material he's very meticulous about it
you know if he talked to Willie as good
as he is he wrote everything right yeah
and he I remember him telling me goes
bro just if you're going to learn from
me just learn how to ride he goes I [__]
up a lot I burn a lot of bridges he goes
don't take that don't do what I do just
learn how to write that's it he is a
brilliant if you guys don't know Willie
Barcena he had a special on Showtime
that the first 20 minutes were just
[__] pure Brilliance smashing SM I
mean pure Brilliance I sat there and I I
got to ret tape
this and learn but if you see him you
know he writes all day all day you know
he writes all day he writes all night
it's in his mind that's what you know
that's what Willie does and it's a shame
that he can't sell a ticket now you know
he can't sell a ticket cuz that's the
comics you really want to go see
Willie's a very good comic you'll go see
popular Comics then go see Willie and go
I [__] get it you know what I'm
saying so so that was one of your
influences remember he took me on the
road man he took me we did the temp
improv and um I mean I didn't have a
notebook I didn't take nothing there I
wanted like I wanted to do good I wanted
to do good in front of the crowd it's my
first time working that improv and the
second night I was at the at the um at
the condo and Willie comes up to me he
goes he ask me hey bro you think you're
funnier than me I like no you think you
have more jokes than me I'm like no he
goes two days man I haven't even seen
you picked up a notebook or a
pencil is this [__] vacation for you
bro damn yeah he's old school yeah it's
the truth man you know you always as a
comic you always have a job to do right
the comedian that says I'm bored that
guy ain't working because you always
have an hour to WR put it down for an
hour email somebody get back on and I'm
lazy of that too I always sit down for a
little point in my day that I'm better
at I'm better than I was 5 years ago cuz
you have to Evol if you have you have to
sit down [__] I got this thought today I
got that thought today you know whatever
but uh I don't see it I I I don't know
how I uh you know Frank me who Frank me
the fighter Frank me when he went to
Jackson's Camp right the first thing he
says is he goes I can't believe I got
away all these years with not training
how I was supposed to and it's amazing
how I got away with all those years when
not writing to the full capability and
yeah I have stories all I have to do is
write them out and polish them
and you have your material you know you
you're telling your life experiences so
how you doing over there Papa I'm good
you bad [__] you look at you
Stone to the Gils that's it you're done
after tonight what you have to move
tomorrow yeah how many times have you
moved the last year four second time
four [__] times I moved once a year
but then this [__] second time came
up and everything's all right you're
going to be happy I hope so what time
the moving people coming over between 1
and 3: between 1 and 3 so you got to
pack all morning or you're done I'm
pretty much done I just have to get last
couple odds and ends want to need
another cookie right now so you're ready
no no let me tell you something you
[__] move till 11:00 you take a 1
hour nap you help them all move again
what are they banging you out for I'm
going say 80 hour 80 an hour well how
many boxes you got three four hours H
yeah B it's not bad I got to watch this
[__] guy he's good man Le you're good
bro th you'll be good what you moving to
bro uh about Valley Village oh
okay right down the
street sorry about that yeah I'm ready
now you we back we're back [__] like
[__] herpes on the
fifth your [__] tongue
herpes whatever from earlier don't worry
about it you know what I'm saying so
what you never ate a [__] chicks
monkey that good no that's what happens
when you lap that [__] for like
34 40 minutes until she blows a [__]
loaded sta juice in your mouth you know
what I'm saying anyway hey Uncle Joey I
remember the first one of the first
times I saw you we were at um Casa
Latina rosem me bro remember that [__]
old school with the little taco bar yeah
man put the old [__] in there you get
there and they had food out for you like
in a like a Chinese buffet type deal
yeah remember and I remember you said on
stage [__] kill me bro you're all
like there you know there was always
gangsters there you said I'm not [__]
scared of you [__] I'm scared
of the Mexicans with the tight pants
with their [__] hats and their boots
I [__] die man how do you know bro
those are the real gangsters you said
[__] once you go to El Paso and you see
those gangsters that don't say much they
don't even laugh they just sit in the
audience every once in a while they
go as they drink their [__] booze
with the hats and [__] that's real
gangsterism right there man these
[__] ain't nothing with tattoos
jumping up and down like ca Latina on a
Tuesday night [__] with their pants
falling down and [__] you know it's
amazing uh how many [__] nights you
go out I was telling the austino today
yesterday at lunch that when you start
comedy you have to go out yeah you
there's no nights off there's no night
like there's you don't even think about
it because I I might get two spots
tomorrow I and get that much better than
me I don't have time for Al to get that
much better than me you got to be out
doing three spots of night two minimum
one is a bad night now I got to hang for
2 hours maybe I got to spot
11:45 it's Jeff Garcia's room I'm an
hour late it's in west coina but it's
amazing how many [__] rooms we went
to like I learn Los Angeles from doing
comedy I didn't learn Los Angeles cuz
I'm a [__] visitor and I want to see
Los Angeles I land Los Angeles from all
the [__] gigs we drove to bro yeah
Mana Latina to all coyotes tortillas
tortillas all those [__] rooms all
those [__] Sebastian's rooms what's
Sebastian oh my God what rooms do they
have he had [__] scoreboard and
Pomona he had Callie and uh was it
Chino scoreboard and pomon that's where
the [__] scoreboard was and they had
basketball and that remember that was a
[__] nightmare the best one was I
told the story was Rudy's the one in
front of the strip club that was an
Irish puup it's still there oh K's no
k's yeah and one night I went in there
fiend and we were so broke that Terry
drove me so I definitely had I wouldn't
drop the 50 bucks that's how broke we
were that my girlfriend's like how much
you getting 50 bucks but I'll be back at
11 no no I'll come with you and we went
down there when I was on stage some guy
was drunk and threw his wallet up in the
stage and I took it but as I was getting
off the stairs there was a men's
bathroom and there was a wall so it gave
me a minute I opened it up and there was
a bunch of hundreds I took one off the
top I gave the guy back his wall I was
like wow I just made $150 that was a
[__] payday Lee $150 then who was
$29,000 now it was [__] so much more
money 15 years ago and you went out
every night except no Sunday I was at
the comedy store Friday Saturday we
started Monday night and Monday night
Monday night either you had the Laugh
Factory or you were somewhere else on
Monday right I think Sebastian had a
Monday night room yeah somebody else had
a Monday night Tuesday you had CLE
Latina C Latina and something else
Sebastian had room to on Tuesday
Wednesday had wild coyote and Thursday
was the Hop remember the hop in Lakewood
dude oh [__] that's for Felipe you could
pick up a mother and her
daughter right that's where you yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and all these places
Le it wasn't about how much you got paid
it was how good the taco bar was
outside cuz that place had a taco bar
they had a taco bar inside when you made
the left by the pool table right next to
a pool table with forks in it and nose
hair and you didn't give a [__] Lee
that's how good those tacos were you
didn't give a [__] you went over there
and made yourself five or six [__]
tacos all those places had a taco bar on
Monday Tuesdays remember what's the one
down there not hasb yeah they still do
it on Monday nights on Monday nights
when it first started the sunset room
the sunset room yeah man that was
Lobster night or something like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah Martin rizle has
that Martin [__] Rizo Lee stop
napping [__] there ain't no time
for naps we're doing a podcast we
have together and [__] the [__] you know
it's interesting cuz today I asked uh
Gabriel how you know the UFC is going to
Mexico oh they are is that the first
time I don't know I don't I know what's
going on they going to Mexico City
brother do they have a Mexican figh in
at least Kanas oh okay that's good
enough they got they got to help them
with a Spanish but right right but it's
amazing how a lot of people are very
scared to go to the UFC in Mexico City
like that [__] Everybody's scared to get
kidnapped but one of the most
interesting stories if you don't mind
telling them
is about chop now is he is he in jail
right now he's got he got caught bro he
got caught again and he's in there what
happened really so he's should died yeah
break it down for Le and [__] this was
in um December like in 2011 man Chapman
was one of the most wanted criminals of
all time bro he was the first the first
um drug dealer to make the Forbes list
he's a bad [__]
dog he's Robin Hood to Mexico man he
built [__] churches he bu he [__]
built houses schools for everybody over
there man so um he was wanted and I was
at I was where my my parents are from
and we went to go eat late at night we
went to some Marisco's place and I was
with my uncle and we see these two guys
walking and my uncle was like
something's going to get down
something's going to go down what's the
name of this town you're
in and how far from the border it's
maybe like 12 hours from the border
Jesus Christ that's deep that's deep
inside dog so we were in there my
uncle's are like something's going to
something's going to go down he go
whatever you do just [__] pay
attention and just do what they tell you
to do I guess it was normal for those
[__] over there so these two
guys walk in and one of them stood in
the front door and the other one was
talking to the manager I don't know what
the [__] they said so they exited so
then they come back with [__] chapu M
bro he had a [__] vest on and those
fools had two big ass [__] bags so
they walked to each [__] table and
that's this if you guys have a camera or
a cell phone [__] put it in his
bag and me [__] thinking like a
[__] American [__] you [__] a
putting [__] in my bag but I said no you
know what [__] that I got to listen to
these dudes I put my [__] phone in
the bag my uncle did the same thing and
everybody started doing the same [__]
and then he walks in he walks in like
the president [__] waves and he sits
down he sits down and the order whatever
whatever so I was still [__] kind of
in shock like [__] what about something
goes down the [__] are we going to do so
at the end of the night they take off
and then they come back and they give us
back our [__] and they said every sorry
for everything their [__] food's been
taken care of and it [__] took off
dude they [__] B how long you sit
there for [__] like 40 minutes bro you
couldn't do [__] you couldn't even go to
the restroom and what were you thinking
those I was [__] think I knew who it
was but those 40 minutes like what about
[__] something goes down but you know
you can't do anything dude like you're
being hostage and [__] and then my
uncle's like no it always happens like
this this is this is how it goes down
here it's cool just [__] just play
along with them man that's amazing what
Mexico has become yeah they just killed
one of the singers like this week from
where we're from too they just killed
killed them these guys they what they do
is they sing about all the [__] that's
going on but they just give too much
[__] information and they just get
blasted
dude you know what I mean I mean
gangsters gangsters want their story out
they just don't want the details you
know what I mean they don't want like
[__] yeah I shot this guy in here and
this and that and this is what I use to
kill him and [__] like that I mean they
want their [__] out there they just
don't want people [__] telling them
all the details you know what I mean and
they just blasted one of those dude
today he was coming out of the sushi
place right there and they just shot him
it's amazing what's happened to Mexico
it's amazing to what Mexico means to the
drug trade it's the [__] you know and
they're not [__] around no more no
hell no like they just snatched half
that [__] from the Colombians they just
they're in everything they do meth they
they still send Brown weed to the
[__] States you know they're still
send them Brown weed to the states not
everybody has [__] $22 a [__]
Grand to buy every day you know some
people are [__] poor they got $77 and
they wanton an ounce for $7 it's dirt
weed it's like Hustle and Flow that's
what they [__] smoke you know uh they
could they're sending Coke weed heroin
meth it's like you know it never ends
with these [__] Mexicans they don't
give a [__] Paula's uh mom was saying
that her her sister has kids and for the
girls in Mexico like it's good it's like
they they wish to be married to drug
dealers like there's just no other way
to make money and then like it's like
not down upon to like marry a drug
dealer listen man drug dealing is uh
especially at that level right what's
going through Mexico you know this is
all Miami 30 years ago now you go to
Miami that's cut cocaine you want
cocaine you got to go to Texas to get a
grma blow it's [__] pure
it's you know you look at the Rocks it's
got a picture of the [__] Chapa
Guzman every [__] rock it just really
you know I haven't bought Coke in seven
years but I saw the trend because I used
to travel across the country and I would
buy coke at different places and I
bought Coke one time you know all the
time I'd buy coke in Miami and it was
okay once I went into Texas whether it
was Houston Dallas you know those border
towns I was snorting [__] electricity
bro Jes and you know if you talk to
Jerry loka where all those guys are from
Corpus they're all that that Mexican
Mafia is there and they're moving [__]
up and that's the reality of it man you
know and people I love when they show
you a tunnel you know well guess what
[__] they got 80 of those you got one
ha and you're on TV with three dudes
with a suit on telling everybody you
solved the mysteries of the world no you
didn't they got 79 more of those
[__] in fact they had one that
was coming right downtown right do you
remember that they found one no they
found one that came downtown all the way
from Mexico all the way from Mexico
right downtown somewhere by a bus
station you know they got the [__]
they got the the way to [__] keep
them cool they got the way to keep
oxygen down there they got the systems
how to [__] run it back they they
just go for it listen when they they're
businessmen right those guys are as much
businessmen as the CEO of [__] Disney
they know if they send out eight loads
two of them are going to get
confiscated that's just the cost of
doing business when they're figuring out
their daily take that goes into the
[__] you know they already know if
they have 10 caves two of them are going
to get caught you know so they're going
to [__] push that coke through there
I mean right it's what the city has if
you think this uh uh country of Mexico
makes money selling straws when you know
selling straw hats when you go to ton
[__] good luck you know they're like
Colombia was I guarante Mexico has loans
with the United States oh I'm pretty
sure they do how you think they pay
their loans back by selling straw hats
and Viva Mexico t-shirts and [__] like
that [__] no by selling [__] blow
guess who sells him that [__] blow
who gives him passage way to sell that
[__] blow we do because God for bit
we get in the way of us make getting our
money back it's a [__] cold world out
there man people don't believe that but
it's the truth all that [__] they're all
cartels to to so there are mules there
are mules they really the United States
mules who controls that [__] you think
three [__] Indians put that deal
together
no is that what you [__] think
[__] it's [__] crazy world out
there bro even even even the baseball
player y pu the Cuban guy he paid
Mexican Mafia to [__] cross him over
over here and he owes them money and now
he don't want to pay it which that guy
will be dead he keeps [__] around you
know they got Security on him they know
the story Major League Baseball's
watching him you know Major League
Baseball watches him before they [__]
even get to the city they go to the
stadium and look in the hotel Look Under
the Bed you know Fidel might send one of
his [__] boys you never
know and Fidel's [__] serpents don't
[__] miss you know what I'm saying
they come over here in fact they the
cops give them the gums at the airport
when they come over and the paperwork
here's you can find Lisa at he's a
[__] Sherman Oaks at the [__]
Italian place eating a rib sandwich what
else is going on man that's when you've
been doing comedy for I've been doing 12
years now man and when did you hook up
with fluff I hooked up with fluff like
an old 6 at the wild coyotes really I
met him through Felipe and at what level
was Fluffy in 06 last year which was
basically what eight years ago he was
about to blow to blow up I remember he
was doing a couple of theaters but now
he's [__] like you knew he was going
to blow up he was doing a couple fees
but he was selling tickets he was
selling he was sell doing improvs still
I remember we're doing Wednesday through
Sundays still with them two shows
Sundays one show Monday they remember
them adding shows man right that those
were the show two years ago wow yeah he
was just [__] doing it already man
and he was just a nice guy and told me
yeah I think you're funny um let hook up
and he's helped me ever
since it's you Martinez it's uh Rick
guerzo Rick Gutierrez Rick Martinez Rick
Gutierrez is part of it and Martin
Moreno Martin Moreno yeah then Ivan quar
is still there with him he's the road
manager the road manager and then
[__] big fluffy man that's amazing we
were talking about today what level you
know I remember taking planes with him I
remember we're both getting the same
money I remember uh doing the Laugh
Factory with him he was always a very
nice kid you know and he always made you
smile and stuff I mean there's nobody I
like being around I see him twice a year
for 10 minutes you know I don't want to
go to his shows cuz I never want him to
think like I could have drove to bird
Bank last night and hung with you guys
and drank you he's got 90 people there
you know what I'm saying uh it's very
today I had a great time with him and
Martin because I I had him for an hour
that's the most I'll see him you know
but it's amazing what's happened to him
and he's never changed and you know he's
always looked out for me he always gives
me something once a year he throws me
[__] something this came up two days
ago he called Martin called me he goes
well he's in town he wants to stop by
and do your podcast I go that's funny
cuz [__] uh robl my main man pizza
pizza pizza pizza was going to do your
uh podcast and then it's funny how you
and I hooked up it was really weird we
were both doing I got asked to do a
weekend with fluffy in
Sacramento and uh it was you myself and
who else I think noi and Jean Poma
Wednesday and Thursday Wednesday and
Thursday and fluffy is going to come up
Friday Saturday
Sunday what year was that bro bro I was
still yes I was still out of my mind 07
maybe or 06 right
07 0
06 I was still out of my mind like yes
it was 06 cuz Gabriel was on Last Comic
Standing yes remember that's why he was
missing that's why he was missing those
days and me and Gabriel me and um you
had to get up on Thursday morning and do
radio right and went to do radio and
Jean was either drunk from the night
before
or just crazy and he picked a fight with
me and then he goes well [__] you
something about Joe Rogan and we started
arguing about pizza I don't even know
what the [__] it was bro right right
ever since that time I see you like
pizza pizza pizza
pizza and then I did the show Thursday
night but that Thursday some the
weirdest no that Thursday that Thursday
the weirdest [__] thing happened I
get a call from ma du's manager agent at
the time and he goes hey man they're
looking for you
for my Name is Earl right I remember and
I go what the [__] are you talking about
my agent
[Music]
I they can't find your agent you got an
audition tomorrow at [__] 11 o' so I
had to take a plane down and my name
isur but in those days it was quick you
went in there they told you and they
said call your client back and tell them
we're going to fact some more sides
right to get to come back and you had to
wait so I went back there like at 4:00
and I was embarrassed I never call
fluffy back he was mad at me for two
[__] years the whole thing plus I was
mad at Jean right and you know in those
days I was still doing blow and I just
wanted to avoid anything that was going
to put me back in jail the last you
can't snore Coke in prison you know what
I'm saying so if I had a feeling in
those days I was going to have a problem
with you was I just avoided you like the
plague you know so that's how we came
about that's where we uh that's where we
bonded bro but I don't know what
happened it was either we went out that
night after the show and we Pizza Pizza
up or something yeah we [__] ate we
bought that pizza at the Walgreens bro
the Frozen one who ate that [__]
thing yeah it was like a Lisi at night
remember it it's not we ate a pizza at
[__] Walgreens at Walgreens bro we
took it back to the room [__] just
chill dog and just talk [__] like
always that's amazing how I met all you
guys individually over the years and
were still together in a way or two and
those rooms they bonded you when you did
those $40 [__] rooms those night Jeff
Garcia's
and you know I remember the [__]
Monday before I got Spider-Man too bro
it's crazy as it seems before I got The
Longest Yard it was Jeff who I borrowed
40 bucks from and he gave me the rest of
the cigarettes he had to go to Santa Fe
New Mexico oh yeah I saw him up at Ernie
G's room Ernie [__] G Ernie G used to
book what's the place up at the
universal the [__] rumber room the
rumber room no that's on Wilshire that
was the Rumble Room bro where's the
rumble room upstairs at at the the
universal cityall oh that's the room
yeah let me tell you something you know
how many [__] sets I did that Rumble
Room on a Monday night how many [__]
200 a year W it was every Monday whether
it was three people or 40 people Ernie G
did it and you know in those days I had
to get the Coke in me so I had to go out
and hustle so if I did three rooms I
could make 80 90 bucks I could buy a
[__] jbo get a taste for 30 and I can
still take home a couple dollars those
days but I had to do three sets Lee wake
up [__] so I have to go out and i'
have to [__] bang it out you have to
stay up at 1: in the morning doing sets
but I tell you what Ernie always put me
up that was a good [__] room up there
too [__] was always sometimes you went
up there and it was like 40 people
sometimes it was 60 on a Monday and you
know what that [__] would stand
outside Lee say what you want he would
[__] I mean that's annoying that's an
annoying trait to walk up to people and
go hi what are you doing right now why
don't you come to this comic show it's
only 795 that [__] drives me [__]
crazy when people come up to you with
that type of [__] on the street Ernie
would do it yeah he didn't give a [__]
or you get there and look inside go
Ernie there's no [__] people and he
go watch this and he go out in that
[__] thing with flyers and drink
coupons and before you know it man he
had 30 people in there and while the
show was going on now was contagious all
right right 10 people would walking at a
time by the time you get up on stage
there' be [__] 80 90 [__] people
man it's amazing in the marketing then
this is way before Twitter the way
before before Myspace yeah this is
before Myspace this is
before all that [__] it's just uh Jesus
it's it's so different now huh yeah way
[__] different man it's crazy how I
[__] how he evolves and how
everything [__] just changes dude
Jeff Garcia was the first guy that throw
me up on stage man where at I seen him
at the at the Casta Latina that was the
first time threw up that was F's room
too F's room bro I seen him at the Ice
House
and he was I remember I was working at
Old Navy I used to do their loss
prevention and uh he had just got off
stage and I se seen him in the restroom
and I was just talking to him and he was
like Hey you think you're funny give me
a call I have a room and I go yeah cuz I
want to do I want to start doing comedy
yeah give me a call and I called him and
he gave me three [__]
minutes three I [__] bought for those
three minutes but I [__] did it dude
bro that's the that's part of the thing
oh yeah yeah and it was funny cuz I was
like what about [__] if I don't have
three minutes he will just stay up
there all right man you know and for the
people at home that they probably listen
you like three minutes Jesus Christ 3
minutes the first four times on stage
seems like three
hours you wouldn't [__] even dream of
it wow if I put you right now if I said
ready 3 minutes click yeah you look at
me and go Joey come on I can do this
with my eyes closed no you couldn't not
there's 100 people staring at you and
the lights to hot and your adrenaline's
up you won't think of [__] it's like
when I first started Jiu-Jitsu once you
got me on my back I was done cuz I was
too busy breathing freaking out about
the situation I'm on my back your mind
is telling you to freak out but once you
it's the same thing with the stage
you're funny when you're in a corner you
know if I go to drink water and you come
over to the thing go hey man what's up
you s that live last night oh my God
yeah and then we start goofing on it
could be funny
that changes
completely when there's lights on and
there's 150 eyeballs looking at you and
I've seen it a thousand times I've seen
people that I know people who say
there's a big difference between people
who say inside that I'm funny on that
guy on TV I could do it and then there's
other brand of people who tell out loud
I went to acting class with this jerk
off years ago Big Time jerk off from the
East Coast New York New Jersey and one
night he's like hey man I want to come
down to the club and watch you do comedy
and he came down he said that was
amazing but you know what I think I'm
funny in you and I'm looking at this guy
and about a month later he calls me he's
like hey man after I saw you that night
I got on stage and I'm doing a showcase
and I think I'm going to a place thing
in Montreal where they [__] whatever
he goes see this he goes I knew it I
knew it you were wasting your time
you've been doing comedy for 10 years
you got nowhere this guy was telling me
this
he goes I did it three days and already
I'm going to a festival I'm thinking of
getting there I'm not [__] kidding
you I never heard from the guy for about
two months and I called him I go hey man
what's happening you end up going to
Montreal and he looked at me he on the
phone he goes let me tell you something
that is the hardest [__] business
that you do he goes I did it like four
more times what a bunch of bullshitters
what a bunch goes I gu told me I was
going to go to Montreal and then they
came down the guy told me I was no good
and it's a [__] [__] battle in the
beginning and that level that's why I
see these guys still and my dick gets
hard because I [__] know how hard it
is man especially out here yeah and
especially back then bro doing like the
Felipe's rooms I remember [__] Felipe
used to throw you up on stage back then
I would only have 10 minutes and that
[__] and Felipe will never light you
Felipe will go out he'll Blaze he had to
do what he had to do he'll never like so
you're up on stage you're supposed to do
10 and then you're up there you look at
your watch you go f I've been there for
20 minutes and fipe will leave you up
there dude that's how you learned that's
how you learned back then that's those
were amazing let me tell you something
everybody knew that when you went to
Wild coyote yeah after two comedians you
were dead you just basically went up
there to go through verbiage I love when
you went to Wild coyotes and people
would show up with cameras to tape a set
you know with three guys this is a
mantra all set and you wouldn't even say
nothing to him you wouldn't even say
nothing to him like you're you're
wasting your time don't even put the
camera on in fact put it back in the car
and tell those guys to go home cuz
somebody might [__] steal it you know
that's how [__] bad wild coyote was
you were just going up there if if
Willie had it you were dead yeah once
Willie got off you would just going up
to the lip sync there was nothing left
in that room will remember willly would
[__] do an hour do an hour up there
bring chicks up there [__] show drink
and [__] sh Lee wake up how can you be
rolling your eyes like this get up do
what jumping jack put the air on
something I can't reach the air yes you
can you're a tall dude reach the jump up
get on the table no jump up and down
look at the shade you can't be this High
we still got to go out we're going out
tonight no we're not we're going to
Denny's we're going to get a milkshake I
already had a milkshake from where in
and out when before you got here so you
went to In and Out you had the wings and
you had the sandwich look at the [__] I
got the shake what type of shake
chocolate large or small did you go to
the window or did you drive through the
window window look at the shape of you
[__] what am I going to do with
you huh I don't know unfuckable that's
no more cookies for you than what time
did you take that cookie bro I don't
know 4 3 3:30 you could have taken that
3 it would have wore off by now but he
cried till 3:30 he took little bites
outfit I'm like bite the thing he was
taking little bites he's [__] Jewish
you know it's like the Heart of Jesus
you know when your cats give you a
cookie that's how you bite it like a
half a fruit cake he was taking little
bites I'm like bite that [__]
COA something burning it could be this
building as we speaking you imagine we
get the black people thr us out of the
other building and now there's a fire in
this [__] building I can't [__]
win now the [__] firefighter can't
come through cuz of the way you're
parked bro we're all going to [__]
die that's wor now the now the funniest
thing about
fluffy you know listen when I came up
Carlos man was a hot property you know
and then it was then it was uh you know
Pablo was the new Next Big Thing then it
was Jeff Garcia had a deal then it
was you know nobody really looked that
fluffy you know nobody really looked
that fluffy and he just took off from a
Comics point of view and listen man I I
could tell you Lee knows I've never had
a problem with fluffy you know that I've
never ever said anything I knew from the
beginning I knew where his heart was
from day one
and he had some Beauties he had some
beautiful people who just got mad at him
from the beginning and uh and I think
they're childish and jealous it's know
which he's got in the way you know but
it's amazing like I'm not surprised he
has a concert film coming out and you
guys are a part of it I mean to see you
guys together on the road is brilliant
and you know what I'm talking about no I
know what you're talking about dude
Gabriel he he tells you straight up dude
he goes I don't want no drama between
anybody I just want everybody to be cool
and that's all I want and everybody just
goes with that dude he just he's just a
nice guy he helps you out as much as you
can I mean he put me on standup
Revolution season 3 season 2 and season
one I'm the only comic that's been in
all the [__] Seasons he put me on his
DVD theoha fluffy and he's [__]
putting me in his [__]
movie and he's going to help me do a
special so I mean the [__] you know he's
helping me out a lot so it's all good G
was one of the nicest guys you ever and
then I'm not just saying that CU I work
for him he's dude he's I see the way he
treats his fans and I see the people he
the way he treats everybody he's just a
nice guy dude some people have it I
can't be like him I'm not a nice dude
like him I'm a nice wayn another way but
I mean that's why more power to him dude
listen man I was minding my own business
my phone rang it was Martin Moreno I
thought he was going to check in and say
he's a Flappers tonight swing by and he
goes hey man Gabriel wants to know if he
could do your podcast and my heart
stopped my my heart Stu here's the guy
that's doing The Tonight Show and and uh
what's Craig whatever what's he doing
he's doing all of them to promote that
movie right and he took 20 minutes out
of his day an hour to do my podcast I
don't have a [__] Sensational podcast
this is just two [__] guys talking
[__] this isn't you
know you might like Get A Life Lesson
out of here you're not going to get
nothing if you're into that stuff but
just the fact that he remembered me you
know what I'm saying that's listen man
in this life and in this business
especially people always say to me bro
this guy called Jim be like when Jim
Jeff had the show he they called me and
I didn't get the show I would never be
mad at Jim Jeff in fact I'm happy he
called me in Steve Burn called me in two
weeks ago for his [__] show I was too
young okay it's the people who don't
call you in who don't think about you I
would never get mad if Gabriel got a
show in a head audition it would mean
nothing to me right I would go in there
and knock it out of the park that means
I'd have to be better than everybody
else so the two people that they wanted
I got to go [__] them up you know what
I'm saying but it's amazing how uh he
treats you guys on the road how you guys
get along I mean things have changed now
because he's trying to get in shape it's
not the old days where you guys went out
to a restaurant andon and shut the
[__] Wing down and Order 50 [__]
tacos Lee you would die you would die
I'll never forget that one night after
San Jose we went to that uh Mexican
place around the corner next to our
suitar right and we sat in the back and
they brought salsa and chips and cheeses
and [__] burritos and brain and pig
eyeballs and they and it was just I had
to [__] excused myself get the [__]
out of there this is these guys were
eating like they were going to the chair
the next morning you know that was every
day bro that was every day three meals a
day you know they wake up at 2:00 they
meet at 3:30 they eat till 5: then they
go to the club they eat again in between
shows and then right after [__] two
hours of signing and three or four
taking pictures they go take a wing from
a [__] Diner and go bring it you know
George was telling me about chance
dragging in when you guys went in Jersey
to the Chinese restaurant with George
[__] he goes they had [__] everything
on that
menu Chu Cho Chui Le woo they had
everybody on that [__] that's
how you do it and you know what man when
you go out like that I wish I made that
type of money that could go out as a
family not with my wife and my daughter
but with as a family with you and three
[__] feature ax and [__] a [__]
manager to count the Gus and a bus
driver and another guy just to control
just to roll joints and play the [__]
music pick something you know what I'm
saying and if we're out of batteries
he'll pick up a guitar and sing a
[__] cionet you understand me Le Lee
look at the I'm never [__] with you
again [__] [__] Lee man no more
cookies cookies no more nothing for you
look at the shape of you I can't take
you nowhere with you blue you look
handsome today you got look you got
Barbecue on your shirt all right blue
cheese on my shirt yeah blue cheese on
your
shirt the wings drip down your face yeah
so I was going to ask Gabriel but I got
too high and I didn't want to ask him
like I was thinking about it last night
cuz ask BR ask me bro what what you
going to ask him well it's both of you
guys but it's cuz when you told me it's
was going to be honest I like all right
let me think of a question I'm like
there's some comedians out there who
have like how Gabriel makes the noises
sometimes they have that kind of aspect
to their act right but a lot of comics
and people don't respect them but like
somehow like Gabriel not not gets away
with it but people don't seem to be mad
about it there's a bunch of like really
active loud comedians who people like oh
that's not real comedy but Gabriel seems
to like they seem to respect Gabriel you
know what dude you're going to get
haters no matter what type of Comedy do
I I I I still do tell tell a lot of on
liners and people hate on that that's
old style comedy while you're doing that
and they're always going to pick
something dud gab was just a nice guy
he's on top so they're going to look for
anything it seems like they don't really
mess with Gabriel I I mean do they is he
it seems like most people I talked to
about him love him I never really heard
nothing about listen if you go up there
with a guitar people break your balls
right but nobody's ever busted Pablo's
balls no look at him and nobody's ever
busted Gabriel's balls really you know
right right right he does what he does
he does it well
more along the line I I'm a huge fan but
more of the line people like hate on
Dane Cook like that sort of thing about
different style of comedies Gabriel's
and Dane Cook you know what I mean it's
different but it has like some of the
aspects I've heard people say bad things
about Dane Cook you could like kind of
relate to what Gabriel does just like
the noises and then and just the way he
does it and it's not exactly the same
but it was just interesting like I love
and I love Gabriel too but it was just
like what I wonder where the difference
lies like like I said dude Dan Cook was
hot and everybody hated on him because
he was doing a lot of [__] so you know
what I mean that's that's that sucks
people should be like happy for you
Mexicans are never happy
bro it's amazing nobody's ever going to
be happy no no somebody's going to feel
that they got you started somebody's
going to feel that they gave you three
jokes you know all of a sudden you're
finding out that do Joe Diaz is mad at
you he said he gave you a joke one night
at a d and now you don't return his
calls what and you sit there and go
what are you talking about it's like a
guy told me once about Gand leini you
know God Rest his soul he goes I used to
party we G the and he went to his thing
the next we shot a movie together and
like three days later he came back with
a stack of pictures of him and G the all
these people up for weekends you know
this was years before he got The
Sopranos and he said he still remembers
when gini Got The Sopranos calling and
when I got this pilot about a mob boss
his not going to get picked up I'll be
back and blah blah blah and he goes
season two when the show was a hit he
called up gandini you know at the old
numbing and the phix took like a week to
call him back and he goes listen bro I
know what you want you want an audition
for the show I don't control that he
goes listen what happened between you
and me it was a long time ago wrap it up
and let's move on you know I love you
take care of yourself you know [__] like
that and there's people who uh who you
move on man you know but there's people
that you just stick around in this
career you you got their [__] back
and that means let me tell you something
this thing is tough to do by yourself
real tough BR it's tough when you have
friends it's tough when you have people
that care for you or other people that
care for you Comics are always going to
[__] hate bro Comics are always going
to hate something about you listen I may
not like a comic but if I think he's
funny he's funny right yeah me too I'm
I'm one of those people there's some
guys I hate hate that comment I hate
them but there's a lot of guys I don't
like them but their [__] comedy is
superb would I hang out with them [__]
no I don't want to hang and they don't
want to hang out with me they don't want
to [__] hang out with me if you look
look what Gabriel did with Stand Up
Revolution you know Tommy Chun he takes
care that's the most important people
what is the [__] thing of this
podcast to make somebody's dead Gabriel
didn't have to give me a million dollars
to make my day he just called and said I
want to do the podcast made my day made
your day yeah you know Al Rober made my
[__] day every time I see Al he says
something to me Nick Diaz bro Nick Diaz
Anderson Silva what do you think you
hear about that fight yeah man that's
who they're going to put up blee if you
close your eyes one more time I will
[__] stab you to
death what are you going to do Lee we
still got to go out we're not going
nowhere we're going out we're going to
[__] go to haha and have some laughs
you drink a couple of sodas we'll get
you all decaffeinated up and that's it
so when are you thinking of shooting the
special my brother I don't have a date
yet just Gabriel is working on it with
me working with me still so see what's
up man and where you living now I live
in Eagle Rock You got a girl now uh no
you you you've been uh single for how
long been single for two years two years
but you got different women that come
into your life you're a freak and Sh you
tie mother I got a couple of friends you
tie them up and you rub sa on their
[__]
[__] you take it for a [__] hoop
don't you little dirty what are you
giggling about Co suck up the get up get
up throw the chair away you got to stand
up that's for show you got to get some
energy look at you you're like a [__]
moo with no energy you need testosterone
you need [__] everything if you stand
up we'll get you some Mexican food no
I'm not hungry you got to be hungry look
at you I too much every time you close
your eyes you're thinking of two tacos
with onions say well e we and some
[__] green sauce no go to saboya they
don't like you don't like saboya not not
too much put too much Jesus I remember
that taco spot used to take us right
there by by the hop on Lakewood which
one I take you to there was one like
around the corner on
Lakewood we us always go after the after
the Hop and you always I don't know but
you used to take us D this is a spot
right here bro I love tacos simple tacos
I don't like [__]
drama say what you want to say bro King
Taco doesn't bother me right Mexicans
get pissed at you King Taco ain't [__]
[__] you [__] I live in the valley King
Taco [__] [__] King Taco is them you
ever go to King Taco no I don't know
what that is you should on the five
right it's on the five you should stop
I've never on the five well make it your
business to get on the [__] five you
always on the 405 what's the difference
the five the 405 it's on the different
side of the Hill that's the difference
yeah well thank you there Mr [__] GPS
I I didn't know this [__] you know what
I'm saying what else my brother tell me
something good what's the next in the
[__] in the whole thing what have you
been learning lately what have you been
seeing what do you want to do what's
your next move acting bro you really
want to get into the acting side of it a
little bit just [__] trying to lose
weight trying to get you know what I
mean okay what do you want to do say
anything man I just want to move up just
trying to evolve as a comic trying to do
everything bro just trying to just get
my feet wet and
everything my own [__] you know what I
mean you want to sell you you got some
ideas uh for a video Network or
something a little bit a little bit it's
amazing about cristelle Alonzo yeah dude
I remember when she used to answer the
phone at The
Improv Addison right Addison Improv I
would go over there and torture her see
if I could [__] get a blow job or
something like man she's a great lady
she's a great lady I've known her for 15
years easy easy 15 16 years she was a
[__] kid man right when I saw that
pilot I got to tell you it broke tears
in my eyes and for the same reason I was
telling Joe before that that you know
they give all these [__] people you
know you got a Montreal Comedy Central
Isa they take some kid that's not funny
at all not [__] funny at all he has
six minutes and 10 people are behind
them and they give this kid
$250,000 they put them on The Tonight
Show they put them on all these [__]
things and you know what let's face it
you're not [__] ready when you're
doing comedy 5 years so you play the
games you cash a check and they give you
a check happily like they give it to you
like h ha it's 250,000 we think he was
so talented oh my God and then you take
it they hook you up with a riter and the
writer calls up and says that kid's a
[__] stiff you know why he's a stiff
because before we wrote The Thing his
head's already big a comic his head
don't this is just another day in their
life they gave me a check then they
realize his tonight's show blows you
know and they just realize the kid blows
in general he's a good comic and he will
be a good comic not today maybe in 15
[__] years but then you get a guy
like yourself because I know petitioning
you for like Montreal or ComEd Central
something like that you get a guy like
yourself Jerry roach Jerry roach you got
an hour yeah he did on Comedy Central I
don't know if it's on Comedy Central oh
it's on Novo yeah Novo and Netflix maybe
Novo on Netflix you know I mean this
everybody put that [__] phone away I
want you to focus focusing bro everybody
uh gets their time you know but then
again you get these people and you see
them right and you know that you're
spread you know that you're covered
you've been on the road with fluffy for
six years you've done theaters you've
done clubs you've done Holland you've
been in front of every [__] scenario
and they won't even let you go to the
[__] first base but they get this kid
because some guy at CAA says he's good
all a sudden everybody gives in the
[__] world and the guy ends up
[__] blowing cristella Alonzo they
even want to give her money right they
want to give her money they're like
we'll give her like this Puerto Rican
deal we'll give her 6,000 up front we'll
give another six if she makes it to the
store
we give no and then look her show got
put on the [__] air you know and I
didn't I forgot all about that they were
going to shoot a Kevin Hart pilot yeah
they did Kevin Hart's [__] P listen
it's hysterical when Comics come up to
me and they go hey man I shot the Jay
Leno pilot this year [__] I'm going to
rock you know what the network behind
closed doors they go let me ask you
something you want to deal with Jay Len
no you want to deal with jayen no get
the we don't give a [__] if Jesus the
[__] show they don't want to do that
too smart right they don't want to argue
they don't want to argue they don't want
you to call me and go I looked at the
script you took the scene of me [__]
the donkey why because it's [__]
Network T you know how you don't have to
do it now you got to [__] interview
with these people you got to go back and
[__] forth with these people they
want to get the guy like me and Lee who
are hungry who they're going to say hey
remove that sheet from your script and
Lee's going to say yes sir that's what
they want that's why whenever they have
these big names that you know this is
what's a matter Leah burping you're a
[__] mess you just ate a burp that
was so disgusting I could tell because
your left eye got so [__] big it's
like you did a blast on the left side
you didn't have enough for your right
side look at the [__] how bad was that
burp you just inhaled pretty bad and it
went out of your mouth and went back in
when I caught you you looked at me you
and you inhal that [__] then
your lip sealed like she was farting or
something like that disgusting but
anyway I'm just happy that you know
you're still plugging along I'm happy
that uh
you're in the [__] game you know I'm
happy that you're working one of the
best you're going to be in one of the
best concert films of the year you know
hopefully last year was Kevin Hart's
year this year is Fluffy's year you know
and he's earned every [__] you know
he's earned everything man that guy is
uh he works that's he has a good work
ethic and he and he kept it together and
now he's adjusting he knows it's going
to be longer he's losing the weight yeah
you know and uh that that's what it's
all [__] about the end of the day and
and he's taking a sh [__] great care
of you guys so there you guys go after
this now it's your turn to [__]
Blossom 42 what is it 42 or 45 weeks out
of the year that we're working with him
are you serious yeah we have [__]
tour bus so [__] he's non-stop bro he's
non-stop on the tour bus you sleep in
the bus I sleep on the bus that's
disgusting yeah it is that's really just
people [__] in the bathroom no you can't
[__] there so where do you [__] you got
to pull over you got to wait until they
[__] put gas or you got to wait till
[__] we're to our next destination so
you just got to hold it bro and how many
nights do you sleep on the
bus I told you dog that bus [__] [__]
you I only join a band I join the
monkeys it depends like I mean with
Gabriel you work Thursday Friday
Saturday and Sunday and you have a you
have a choice to fly home but I mean the
[__] flights are expensive so you
stay on the bus so you stay on the bus
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and
then you meet up with Gabel Gabriel FES
home you know what I mean and that bus
is shaking people farting the bus people
taking their shoes off yeah is there
food on the bus there's food on the bus
it's a TV there's a TV there's a TV in
the front and there's a TV in every bunk
really yeah so you can watch what you
want yeah you can watch your [__]
DVDs you can do whatever you want you
take a shower on there no you got to
wait until like we hit a whole towel can
you brush your teeth be yeah you can you
can brush your teeth smoke from the bus
yes you can no you can't you can
cigarettes too no cigarettes but weed
you can just straight up weed no cigars
no cigars no nothing oh you can you can
put blunts but I mean weed is cool we
got a bus Le going to be the bus drive
he wants to be a driver I thought about
that I'm going to give you that position
and if you can't hold it bro you get a
trash bag and you go to the restroom and
you [__] and you just [__] throw it
out bro oh no Lee get up that's it throw
away the chair I need you on your feet
Lee look at you you're a young man
you're acting like you're 90 [__]
years old [__] you weigh a half a
little edible 10 Mig you weigh [__]
believe this guy Mig he didn't even know
100 [__] milligrams look at him you
know how it's amazing because you see uh
you you I've been here 17 years so I
learned I I learned the system you see
these guys they come to town they're the
hot [__] thing around their town or
they're on the road with somebody right
and they come to town and the
percentages are you don't [__] see
them you see them for a while then when
they they disappear that one day they
Facebook you and they're like hey man
I'm back in San Antonio remember me
you're coming to town can I open for you
you're like what the [__] happened to
that dude that dude was around all the
time you know you see so many people Le
it's not that you're an [__] or a
scumbag you see so many [__] people
Le you know when you go if you go out to
do comedy three nights a week you're
going to see 70 people you know at least
especially if they're loose comedy rooms
you're going to see 10 comics at every
[__] room that's 30 Comics a night
let's say you go out four nights that's
125 that's 30 * four yeah 120 [__]
Comics a week you know people going to
slip through the [__] you know oh my
God what happened to that [__] guy
but to see you to see you know [__]
uh Martin right you know I was telling
the story might Martin I went to do a
room and Martin was hosting and he got
into an argument with a soldier and
while I was on stage he went outside
fought the soldier then came back and
closed the show up you know I met these
guys on the combat [__] conditions
you know like I was saying you don't
want people to think that we work man
there's a struggle [__] period where
we [__] starve you [__] starve you
know and I had a cocaine problem so I
was starving and I wanted to get high
and I wanted to smoke cigarettes and get
my dick sucked you have all these vices
that you have to make work and it's just
amazing that we're still here today uh
Martin asked a question like why us like
why I mean you didn't grow up with no
Mansion you know your family didn't have
a ton of money you could have done you
could have been a cop but you had flat
feet you stalked the [__] oh that was
Martin that had flat feet that's why
yeah he got kicked out of the the
military the Marines but it's amazing
how you end up here especially as a
comedian you never think T not I was
walking here I was walking to the car my
wife parked around the
corner and I was looking at the palm
trees and I remembered one of my first
jobs out of high school maybe my second
a third job it was at a hardware store
and I worked for George mad he was the
first her I ever knew he ate hummus too
I didn't like him but his guy his father
worked there and his sister worked there
and we used to call his father George
mudad on the Bahama
sound and you know what I had a good job
there bro I would have still been there
do you know what I'm saying like today I
would have still been there they were
nice people and I used to he used to
make me uh prep the deliveries right and
I would put extra [__] in the deliveries
like let's say he would say you know put
I get the order it be a drill a Hammer I
put three drills and the hammer then I
make the delivery and sell the drills
that afternoon and one day somebody uh
so somebody gave me a checkbook or I
took a check somebody gave me a
checkbook asked me if I could sell
checks I said I knew a guy that could
cut them and give you 80% I gave the guy
the check but he got caught and gave him
my name so the [__] funny thing was I
met the guy outside the bank they had a
picture of the [__] van right so
that's how they got me they went back
and went to George mudad and George Mad
said that's my driver ever and I
remember as it was pulling me away the
cops he said Joey I got to tell you
something I've been here for 20 years
you're the best employee I ever had you
would have made it in I never went back
and apologized to that guy never even
went back he believed in me Lee look at
the shape of you
sweating oh my [__] God you know and
you think about how at that moment when
they were putting me in that police car
my first arrest I think I think it was
June 28th
1983 I thought my life was over right 31
years years ago when you were getting
fired off the police force you thought
it was it yeah that's it bro that's it
I'm going to be a gangster cuz I can't
get a job now everybody's KN to know I
got fir from the police so this is never
going to [__] happen for me it really
is amazing guys how when you think
you're [__] down right you still got
so much left man and I could have given
up in my mind I could have you know what
I got I got a [__] possession of
theft whatever it was that's it I might
as well take this life and I did for a
little while but I realized and so did
you I bet after you uh stalk that broad
you said [__] it I'm done now I'm
[__] done the crazy part I remember I
didn't know how to tell my mom that I
got kicked out so for an extra month I
still dress up like I was going to the
[__] Academy and I went to the mall
and somebody saw me there and they
called my mom they're like oh where's
where's Alfredo and this and that like
oh he's in the academy oh we you seen
him at the mall so I came back I put my
uniform back on and then I'm like my mom
sat me down and she what's going on and
I had a tell her right there bro that
was that was my thing right there I was
always scared of my mom dude I always
lied to her cuz I was like I I didn't
really want to lie to her I just I
didn't want to tell her the truth you
know I didn't tell her I got kicked out
till I got caught I remember my
graduation from high school dude I
remember not graduating with my class I
graduated after and I didn't know how to
tell my mom and I remember my whole
family [__] came from Mexico they
[__] flew in and I was like what you
got left back what's that you got left
back in then no check this out so
everybody flew in [__] from Mexico
here for your graduation and I remember
I told my mom to [__] buy my cap and
gown so I was I'm already [__] balls
in I got to [__] do this [__] dude
and I remember my consor telling me you
can march with your class but you can't
go up on stage and receive your diploma
because there's no [__] diploma for
you you got to come to summer school and
get it now [__] it I'll still [__]
play this [__] role dude so I [__]
my whole family went they [__] bought
a camera they went to my graduation I
was [__] waving at them and then I
had to go around the stage bro they
didn't call my name the [__] they
called that guy in front of me and had
to go around the [__] stage bro and
they think he got you a diploma no they
[__] they didn't see me on stage and
they're like why come you didn't [__]
tell us and this cuz I was scared I was
a [__] scared of you lady you know
what I mean but I took it that [__]
deep dude not to tell my mom and [__]
family flew in from Mexico thinking I
was going graduate [__] by a camera
and to record that [__] Alfred's
graduation and nothing look at the [__]
look at this [__] M Del
away look at the shape that's it dog
what it's over for you over there
sweating profus justly and
[__] you look good though you're back
you ready to get a milkshake now Co no
yes you are what can you go for right
now time going go home now no you're not
going to go home what are you going to
do at home pack pack this [__] guy
dog that's all he does is pack he got a
single bedroom he sold half his [__] and
he still has the balls to tell me he's
been packing for [__] 4 days this
Beauty look at Lee get up get up Le get
up get up throw the chair away that's I
need some blood in those legs come on
Lee you're too young you're too young
you're too young how old are you Le 25
25 [__] young dude how old are you
bro 36 tell this [__] dude when you
were doing a 25 right [__] dude hitting
up stages [__] three stages out a day
[__] going up air driving from LA to
Ontario to montabello W she looking for
spots to go up not getting paid bro not
getting paid not getting paid what do
you mean wild [__] suck and I remember
back then dude and if you weren't even
doing comedy you had a [__] hang out
bro that's how you network back then
hang out they [__] let everybody see
your face remember those days
Joey you would go out at
8:00 I would leave my house it's 7:15
7:30 and you just went to different
[__] places it's amazing how many
it's amazing how you brought up a few
names today these guys today brought up
a few names sometimes you're driving
into it somewhere else and you remember
the exit and you go oh my God that's
where that place used to be remember
[__] going to West CO 40 minutes back
and Chino there was a room on Sunday
nights in Chino that paid $75 that's gas
today yeah it's 50 to go to Chino and
back and gas to that's off the [__]
60 or something yeah it's amazing dog
it's amazing that I learned how to
[__] navigate myself through LA from
the rooms it started with Rudy and know
Hammer the bra and just went everywhere
else man listen man I'm happy I got to
get you on there I wanted to show people
that you're a bad [__] to
follow you you know thank you man and
I'm happy that you're with Gabriel and
they're taking good care of you and
you're coming out the movie July 11th
July 11th and uh what it going up
against what other the movies are coming
out that week I think that um the Planet
of the Apes part two or something like
that what else that's all I know okay
that be [__] deep it'll be good man
and thank you for having me bro I'm a
big fan [__] love you dog ohg Pizza
Pizza one of the realest guys around
Joey [__] Diaz every time and leis
say every time I see this guy he puts a
smile on my face man listen when I go
out sometimes like you've heard all the
stories you hear all this [__] and then
you go out and you see these Comics like
how you doing they start telling you
about what they did and what they doing
when I see an ow it's just chill it's
just a joke or two he bro what do you
think about this fight bro he tells me a
Mexican Mafia story my dick gets hard
and that's it where'd he go I don't know
he he was here he left you going out
with us not no no you're going out with
us okay this the party is stopping
you're not going anywhere I'm going to
the ha you're going home I'm not I got
nothing to do what am I going to do I
told him I'm going to the ha I'm going
to go meet out going to do a spot let's
go to the ha what are you going to do go
home and do what whack off stop being
high you know what no you're never going
to stop being high oh don't say that I
gave you the deck of dose you're going
deep plus you're going to eat another
half of cookie now before we get off let
me give a shout out out to my [__]
sponsors you know what I'm saying I
don't know when this one's going to a
sometime next week but let me give a
shout out to an it one of the best
[__] sponsors out there honest to God
because their products work I wouldn't
have somebody on this podcast if they
suck dick I love on it I love from the
shroom Tech I love the the the the the
strong bone the Alpha Brain is just
tremendous they got a money back
guarantee they every time I go on their
web page I see something else on there
which lets me know they're working
they're always Innovative go to on.com I
think they off offering 10% off you
press what in the Box Lee church church
CH you are CH get 10% off get on the
list and also have the stay on it
program with them mail it directly to
you at the house in the first of the
month also a big round of applause for
Dollar Shave Club one of the best
[__] people out there don't forget
about Father's Day on Dollar Shave Club
they got gift cards go to my Joey di.net
go to Dollar Shave Club box and press
Church Church C hu CH and get the deal
of a lifetime for razors no more going
to [__] stores and standing online
you know the average month of razors
cost you like 11 [__] 12 20 [__]
dollars you know how much it cost you
with Dollar Shave Club how about $1 $6
and $9 get that again you're like Joey
you're bullshitting me that's right
[__] what you would spending
four months in raises I'll [__] save
you in a year even if you get the $9
plan cuz 9 time 12 is what Lee 108 are
you [__] kidding
me it don't matter it's somewhere over
there do the math yourself we ain't no
[__] calculator here sucker go to
Dollar Shave Club they got braids
Dependable they last
forever that's what I use I've got one
ingrown hair this [__] year they're
tremendous they also have the [__]
wipes your ass smells like peppermint
they have the preep the the the shaving
cream which stops the [__] buffing on
your face they got everything go to
Dollar Shave Club go to the box and
press bam if I tell you once I tell you
a million times there's nothing like
Hulu plus.com with the emphasis on plus
they ain't [__] around no more they
got tremendous shows what kind of shows
they got Modern Family what else they
got on there they got new shows they got
the nightly shows like The Tonight Show
and Letterman and any device you got any
device Roku chinu Wang those aren't
devices iPad what else you're not naming
devices I'm just [__] around I think
those were some of the Chinese food
dishes you were talking about ear what's
the [__] what's
the smart TV Roku Apple TV Xbox
PlayStation pretty much any streaming
device you [__] own it took an hour
and a half but I'm back shut the [__] up
[__] you got Hulu plus.com that's how
we roll go to Hulu plus.com and go there
and pressing what Joey because Hulu Plus
is so much more pressing [__] Joey
get shows like Modern Family The Daily
Show and Scandal on the [__] on you
got Nashville lws you could binge watch
him you can do whatever the [__] you
watch go to Hulu plus.com sign up today
you get two weeks for free and $77.99 a
month what's the code Joey Joey J OE Y
and also like to give a shout out to one
of the best flotation tank companies out
there escapod tank.com you understand me
ask for the just the the model tank get
150 off just the tank it's a beautiful
model I'm stoned to the gills it don't
matter listen Jeremy's a great guy you
call him up
he's got the answers to all your [__]
questions you might call Jeremy up with
astronomical [__] question about the
stars and Shakespeare and he'll be right
there on the 8009 that's how Jeremy
rolls go to escapod tank.com look at
their tanks they got commercial tanks
they got residential tanks you want them
to install it they'll [__] install it
you got somebody to install it you just
want to send out the tanks go out there
look at that you're going to save
thousands per tank anybody else got
these tanks for three 4GS more not a
skap pod tank
all right go to a skap pod tank and
press in just mention Joey just mention
[__] Joey all right Diaz Jew sandals
[__] hummus and you get $250 off and
with that you can save money have
somebody come over the house and install
it for you right I got cotton
mouth we saw each other the I the other
night last week player yeah that was fun
back back Lee is back it's about time
this [__] over you [__] up today I got
here I'm here what's going on are you
ready for another one no for a little Ed
one no thank you you guys thank you for
giving us another week of the church
thank you very much for staying up late
and watching this tonight I little
thanks my man our Ro as you know I love
you all my heart bad [__] look
for him The Fluffy Movie coming out July
11th and also to my main man Lis one of
the baddest [__] Jews out there he
came to a realization his grandmother
was in a [__] camp for 3 weeks
suffering so you could be an American
[__] you probably held your baby
not what you said shut up cocksuck I
said I ain't no I ain't no Donald
Sterling yes you are said no I'm [__]
not Donald Sterling would love it if you
came out and started saying [__] I love
the Jews you know thatu I just tell you
how it is your grandmother suffered in
there for you not to eat edbl you got to
get it together you slip it whenever I
offer you an edible you got to say yes
Captain Kirk you want to hit this pen
before you leave no Captain Kirk I come
not this is tremendous oh dude I was so
high I was like falling asleep back
there it's like like a little cozy woman
here how can you be [__] huh you're
the man with the power you get more
booty calls 15 after every hour that'd
be nice all right read what you got to
read let's get the [__] out of here nice
now that the show's over don't forget to
sign up for your free trial Hulu Plus
Hulu Plus let you binge on thousands of
hit shows thousands anytime anywhere on
your TV PC smartphone or tablet support
this podcasting is an extended free
trial of Hulu Plus when you go to Hulu
plus.com Joey or go to joy.net and click
on the Hulu Plus Banner don't forget to
sign up for dollarshaveclub.com get high
quality razor Senter your door every
month for a fractional what you pay
retail now go to
dollarshaveclub.com church or just go to
jobs.net and click on the Dollar shap
Club banner and again thank you to skap
pod tank.com go there and get money off
of sensory de pration tank boom I made
it
[Music]